gone home consolidations coming out and
so is that dragon cancer which you
actually just played I just played this
morning I finished right before it came
into the studio so you're super super
happy right now it's a it's a it's a
moving game and you know it deals with a
couple whose child is dying and they
have other children and they sort of
have to navigate the waters of you know
coping with the impending tragedy coping
with explaining this to their kids you
can't actually understand what's
happening struggling with faith and
faith is something that you know I was
forced to go to church as a kid but I
never it never really struck a chord
with me this game obviously didn't like
change my mind about that yeah but it
provided a very interesting look into
how faith can affect the way people deal
with problems and how they might deal
with things when they lose faith and how
that that absence uh is in a way both
good and bad for groping and
understanding ditchling I I felt I'd
like loads of weird Catholic like
growing up Catholic emotion that the
very I was very very Catholic until I
was in my teens and had quite a lot I
feel like I had a rough transition out
of Catholicism and we're bioshock
infinite I really tapped in summer
knutson but this game is actually well I
don't spend too much time on any one of
these but just because you've literature
cited and this is also developed by
somebody who this is like a real story
this is this actually happened to the
developer there are not many
autobiographical games out there this
one is like you can't get more
autobiographical than this yeah they're
they're voicing it they're dealing with
their own experiences they're creating
these these abstract interpretations of
their own emotions and thought processes
and and yeah and like you really feel
like you get to understand how they feel
I am the one thing I think is a game
could have been a little bit longer hmm
because there are these moments where
it's so heavy and then it pulls back and
then before you know it they've sort of
like gotten over a hurdle and you feel
like man I just don't know if like I got
the brunt of everything that they went
through that said it yeah like this is a
very personal story and
it it's got it doesn't play all that
well but play isn't important here yeah
that's not what it's about review on
gamespot soon yes it is a you know it's
a special special game so we're giving
the review special attention right
written right now we're figuring out how
to put the finishing touches on it yeah
and you should see it either well today
or tomorrow cool talk games review yes
right so that we had a freelancer do it
came to even decide to review like it's
kind of a yeah so that was a question
yeah we scored this game um yeah and but
Justin Clark are freely enter wrote an
amazing review and yeah okay more you
guys to see it because this game needs
to be talked about and people need to I
think experience it and it's one of the
first games I was terrified to play
right not because it was scary but
because like I didn't want to confront
my own fears of death yeah I own fears
of sorrow and I'm know I'm not the only
one hmm it'd be very hard for me to play
ya know if I can do it yeah I lost two
grandparents are cancer cells yeah it is
a tough game all right let us know in
the comments actually if you if you've
if this again you're not excited by
interested in playing or have played and
is it have now it's out now okay cool so
you can go pick a steam yeah 15 bones is
pc only uh Mac PC yeah for now so yeah